Hey Conan O'Brien here with some
exciting news that's why I turned around
in a very dramatic fashion I have long
thought that I had pretty cool style
until recently I was walking the office
and I said to some of the young people
that work for me what do you think of my
style they said Conan you need to
refresh and you need it now I thought
that was rude so I fired them hired new
young people they said the same thing so
I decided to get wise
I contacted Chinatown market this is an
amazing company
Gabi Mike good to see you you sir are
the founder of Chinatown market Gabi
thank you for being here as well very
talented stylist designer let's be
honest what do you think about what's
going on with me right now I think we
could do a little bit of rework on this
don't be an [ __ ]
we got yourself some prizes you got some
surprises oh wow bang I'm curious Gabi
you designed this how did you get the
exact contours of my hair because you
have it perfectly yeah it required many
reference pictures what did you notice
about my hair you're studying all these
photographs it um morphs it changes
different angles different lighting the
swoop I'm like one of the x-men yeah
except that I my power doesn't really
miss my hair changes in different
photographs it's not very useful I'm
excited to see what's next we made you a
special edition jacket oh my god this is
amazing
you've sort of captured a little bit of
a sadness in the eyes when I try this on
of course thank you very much this is
great
Gabi doing if I use you for a second
sure you were the hostess at like a
really exclusive restaurant I'm very
very exclusive I'm gonna come in and I'm
gonna ask you if I could have a table
for one you say I'm sorry sir we're full
then I'm going to show you the back of
my jacket and I want you to be blown
away and say we'll always have room for
you cool dude got it yes here we go oh
hello I'm very hungry I wonder if I
could have a table for one oh sorry
we're full full are you yeah really
oh well now that you've turned around
and I see your faces on your jacket
we'll always have room for you cool dude
thank you
and see what else should be looking at
here some shoes that we brought for you
is the
Coenen name or likeness anywhere on
these we thought you'd like those just
for personal that's really nice thank
you
oh my God look at this this one comes
from the brain of Gabby this is an anime
body pillow in your likeness is the idea
that this is in bed and you just snuggle
up against it
yeah or you know go out to dinner it
looks so sad if I put this opposite me
in a restaurant yeah and ordered a glass
of wine for it as well I have to
congratulate you both these clothes and
this merchandise is absolutely fantastic
this stuff would make anybody look cool
and I'm gonna prove that right now by
getting in my associate producer I think
this stuff could make shortish Lansky
look far better than he does now hello
Jordan hi good to see you good to see
you as well we can take your hands out
of your pants if you like I'm
comfortable this way I'm sure you are
I'm wearing this amazing merchandise
mm-hmm and I think if you wore it you
would look so much better but first I'm
gonna ask Gabi and Mike to dissect your
look what do you think Jordan I don't
want you to be discouraged they weren't
impressed with what I was wearing right
now I'm wearing this gear and I feel
amazing I think we could jazz you up you
want to give it a shot
sure you okay I don't know that I accept
the fact that my look is uninspiring and
that yours was superior to begin with
but for the purposes of this practice
I'll take that premise under
consideration okay my favorite times are
when you're not talking oh my god
fantastic Jordan decked out in Chinatown
market this is fantastic
Jordan this is the real you what are you
gonna sing pulls it off he pulls it off
with a certain panache and you said it's
possible to print something on his shirt
is that nice we have our magic printing
gun here you need a phrase from me that
I want printed on Jordans sweatshirt
tell me anything all right you ready
that is beautiful where have you been
all of my life I think this message will
be popular with millennial consumers
because it's an enviable position to be
in so I do wear this proudly so you
admit that you don't do anything I admit
that I wear this proudly he doesn't
nothing on the show thank you very much
an honor to meet both of you thank you
thank you very much
Jordan and I are gonna go to the clubs
now you know what something tells me
we're gonna do quite well tonight if you
know what I mean what I mean is not
sexual I think we'll probably get some
appetizers and a drink and then we'll be
probably asked to leave after a short
period of time that's all I know